hey there Tony - copal here a new
co-host of CBS this morning we taped
that very show right in this building
not very excited from the street-level
CBS broadcast Center what I want to do
today is give you a little tour of my
new walk to work and then tell you a
little bit about the new show and a lot
about me because you may not know like I
said CBS production Center it says on
the wall I've been corrected it says
broadcast Center on the other wall it
does say production Center they're right
they're not wrong about that all right
but there's the bigger sign CBS
broadcast Center famed entrance to a
bizarre tangle of buildings an entire
block it used to be a dairy farm way
back when one building built on top of
another connected way after the fact
here's the lobby it's probably a little
darker now there shall be light and now
there is all right hello there good
afternoon and through we go usually we
have to swipe a card it was a long
journey to me coming through that
entrance and joining this particular
team I started way back when at a
magazine called Newsweek which probably
you've never even heard of let alone
pick up used to be a big deal had an
internship there wrote a lot of stories
that became TV to the extent that before
I came here I actually had stories on
ABC NBC and CBS that I had reported that
they then picked up then eventually they
were like that guy's hair is way too
good for print and I was like I couldn't
agree more
why don't I join the television ranks
and they said okay we'll try you out and
this is a really tight squeeze these
passageways when I told you these
buildings were built independently and
then put together after the fact this is
the proof little passageway in order to
get to one studio connecting it to a
hallway if you go the other direction
more little passageways if you go down
basement after basement and then there's
actually you can find stalls downstairs
where the cows used to be this was a
dairy farm bizarre place anyway this is
the hallway leading you to the famed
studio 57 this will be my
to work this is gonna get caught so I
started doing print stories those
stories got picked up and became TV and
eventually I was invited to come here to
studio 57 which is right in here I can't
show you everything censored censored
you can see the sign but on May 20th
right behind this door we'll start the
the new CBS this morning or the refresh
CBS this morning or at least a new
chapter for CBS this morning I'm excited
because I thought someone's gonna come
through the door I'm excited because
it's been a long strange journey to here
I've had some very weird jobs even
before I got into journalism washed
police cars one summer worked at Wendy's
worked at Abercrombie for kids pretty
bad the four kids part of it built in
ground pools if you have a pool in
upstate New York
I might have helped dig it for you it's
a busy hallway hi how are you thank you
very much I appreciate it
yes is it we've downgraded a little bit
yes for social it's a social chat thank
you very much yeah we like the brick
wall it's a little bootleg thank you
very much yeah no packing everything
into a three week period
I'll have the job for life and the baby
for life maybe baby thank you very much
I appreciate it
hey social media we're doing social
stuff it's been a long strange trip to
here I did really build in-ground pools
for a summer in upstate New York so if
you this summer are swimming in a
beautiful pool in your backyard
I might have helped build it worked at
Wendy's and then the journalism path was
from print to TV first at MSNBC cable
round-the-clock news covering politics
mostly but I wanted to come here because
nobody does television like CBS we spend
more time with people we have longer
interviews people get their point across
with air to breathe with room to breathe
you can really appreciate where they
come from and what they're trying to say
and that's what I love about TV it is
the original medium it is the human
voice nothing in between you and that
person and their experience and when you
get that on camera
it is absolutely thrilling and it can
change lives and that's why I wanted to
be here